mark the Fed is remaining a patient in
its decision on when to raise interest
rates it is more bullish on the US
economy there's new language in here
about their worries about inflation
running too low but they still expected
to eventually rise towards their two
percent target and they are now also
factoring in international circumstances
financial markets as well as they assess
when to start raising interest rates let
me walk you through this statement first
of all starting with a new language on
the economy information received since
the Federal Open Market Committee met in
December suggests that economic activity
has been expanding at a solid pace labor
market conditions have improved further
with strong job gains and a lower
unemployment rate some of the new
language here on inflation inflation has
declined further below the committee's
longer-run objective largely reflecting
declines in energy prices market-based
measures of inflation compensation have
declined substantially in recent months
survey-based measures of longer-term
inflation expectations have remained
stable they go on in the statement to
say that inflation is anticipated to
decline further in the near term but the
committee expects inflation to rise
gradually toward two percent over the
medium term as the labor market improves
further and transitory effects of lower
energy prices and other factors
dissipate the committee continues to
monitor inflation developments closely
and again as they factor in everything
they're looking at as they decide on
interest rates their assessment will
take into account a wide range of
information including measures of labor
market conditions indicators of
inflation pressures and inflation
expectations and new language here
readings on financial and international
developments based on its current
assessment the committee judges that it
can be patient in beginning to normalize
the stance of monetary policy repeating
that key line from the December meeting
also dropping the previous language
about considerable time as expected the
vote here was unanimous mark they're
more bullish on the US economy they see
low inflation on their radar as a worry
but they still expect it eventually to
move up towards their two percent target
but they're looking at some new factors
out there we'll have to see exactly how
the markets read this latest statement
from the Fed